Let's understand what exactly this shadow page table
is and what it is. In many architectures,
for example, Intel's X86 family, the CPU uses
the page table for address translation. What that means
is presented with the virtual address, The CPU
gets to what? It first looks up the TLB
to see if there is a match for
the virtual page number contained in this virtual address.
If there is a match, it's a hit and it
can translate this virtual address to the physical address. If
it is a miss, CPU knows word in memory the
page table data structure is kept by the operating system. And
therefore what it does, it goes to the page table,
which is in main memory, and retrieves the specific entry
which will give it the translation from the virtual page
number to the physical page number. And once it gets that,
It'll stash it in the TLB, as well, and be able to generate the physical address
that is specified by this particular virtual address.
So that's the way the CPU does the
translation in many architectures. So in other words,
both the TLB and the page table are
data structures that the architecture uses for address
translation. Page table is also a data structure that
is set by the operating system for enabling the processor to
do this translation. So in other words, the hardware page table
is really the Shadow page table in the virtualized setting, if
the architecture is going to use the page table for address translation.